[Musique]
voici mon chat albert l'autre jour alors
qu'il discutait chocolat avec une amie
albert s'est posé la question suivante
est il possible de distinguer juste à
l'oeil une praline belge d'une praline
suisse oui je sais ce n'est probablement
pas le plus grand problème de ce monde
je me demande d'ailleurs qui d'autre sur
cette planète a du temps à perdre
là-dessus alors albert on s'intéresse au
chocolat suisse
tu as bien raison c'est pas que le
chocolat belge est mauvais mais je
t'assure c'est quand même bien meilleure
pour t'aider à distinguer les pralines
belge des prime suisse je te propose de
faire du machine learning la première
étape va être de collecter des données
ensuite on va utiliser ces données pour
chercher une règle qui identifie les
nationalités des pralines
voici un échantillon de huy praline
suisse et un autre de 6 praline belge
seulement j'en ai mangé deux par pur
accident
on pourrait commencer par regarder si la
forme de la praline joue un rôle
tu peux constater albert que les
pralines carrés sont aussi souvent
suisse que belge alors que les pralines
d'une autre forme sont majoritairement
suisses la forme semble donc jouer un
rôle mais c'est loin d'être convaincant
qu'en est il des éclats de noisettes
on voit que les deux prime concernés
sont des pralines belge
ceci suggère que si une praline et
couverte d'éclats de noisettes
alors elle est nécessairement belge mais
la réciproque n'est pas vraie une
praline sans noisette n'est pas
forcément suisse je crois qu albert à
trouver une règle qui marche bien
si une praline est à base de chocolat au
lait ou si elle possède des éclats de
noisettes alors et les belges
dans le cas contraire est le suisse perd
lui albert cette règle identifie
parfaitement les pralines suisse parmi
les pralines de notre échantillon
cependant albert on est peut-être tombé
dans le piège de la surinterprétation
dont j'ai parlé dans les épisodes
précédents pour rappel la
surinterprétation aussi appelé au verre
fusing c'est quand on invoque des
modèles beaucoup trop sophistiqué pour
pouvoir coller aux données en effet le
problème c'est que en s'autorisant des
règles trop sophistiqué ou n'augmentent
la variance de nos prédictions c'est à
dire que d'un jeu de donner à l'autre on
risque de prédire une chose et son
contraire et ça ça fait que les règles
que l'on a identifié ont peu de chances
de se généraliser à d'autres données
fort heureusement il s'agit d'un
problème bien connu des statisticiens
qui ont développé des techniques pour
éviter ce piège
l'une des grandes stratégies pour éviter
la surinterprétation c'est la validation
croisé dans sa forme la plus simple la
validation croisé consiste à diviser
aléatoirement les pralines en deux
groupes le premier groupe est alors
appelée training day to set
le second est appelée testing d atos est
le premier groupe servira à trouver
parmi un ensemble de règles celles qui
prédit le mieux la nationalité de la
praline le second servira à tester la
capacité de la règle retenue à se
généraliser sur de nouvelles données en
particulier cette approche permet de se
rendre compte que c'est normal de faire
des erreurs
in fine est l'objectif du machinerie
c'est de faire des généralisations et
des prédictions à des données qui n'ont
pas encore été observée c'est sûr qu'on
va faire des erreurs
du coup pourquoi ne pas s'autoriser des
erreurs des l'apprentissage des règles
sur les données du training bêta 7 est
une façon de s'autoriser intelligemment
à faire d erreur consiste à rester en
dhr l'ensemble des règles envisagées dès
la phase de training par exemple on peut
commencer par listé une série de règles
à considérer de mort dont nous s'il est
possible de prédire la nationalité du
praline à partir de règle numéro 1
uniquement la forme de la praline
règle numéro 2 à partir uniquement du
type de chocolat
règle numéro 3 à partir uniquement de la
présence ou de l'absence d'éclats de
noisettes
règle numéro 4 à partir à la fois de la
forme de la praline et du type de
chocolat
règle numéro 5 à partir à la fois de la
forme de la praline et de la présence ou
absence d'éclats de noisettes et ainsi
de suite
la question que l'on va se poser pour
éviter le piège de la surinterprétation
est alors la question du nombre de
règles à considérer si on ne choisit
d'utiliser que la première règle
alors on risque fort l'asu
interprétation puisqu'à ce moment là on
aura très peu de flexibilité pour coller
aux données si on choisit d'utiliser
uniquement les deux premières règles
alors on risque encore la soude
interprétation mais on aura plus de
flexibilité pour coller aux données et
plus on considère de règles à considérer
plus on risque de passer d'un régime
dessous interprétation un régime de
surinterprétation et ça ça se voit très
bien si on regarde le nombre d'erreurs
commises en fonction du nombre de règles
que l'on choisit de garder
au début lorsqu'on choisit peu de règles
on est dans le régime de l'ass ou
d'interprétation et les erreurs à
travers le training day tôt 7 et le
testing day tôt cette sombre heureuse
mais plus on considère de règles plus
ces erreurs diminue le point à partir
duquel on passe en régime de
surinterprétation est facilement
identifiable grâce au testing gates est
il est juste ici au delà de ce point le
nombre de règles retenues devient trop
grand et l'ensemble perd sa capacité à
se généraliser
alors ce qui peut paraître embêtant
c'est que le danger de m'assurer
interprétation nous contraint à nous
restreindre un certain niveau de
complexité
or on a vu dans l'épisode 7 que
justement les modèles à grande
complexité de solomonoff sont
indispensables pour une intelligence
artificielle de niveau humaine comment
permettre un apprentissage de grande
complexité de solomonoff censure
interprétation est bien la clé pour du
machine learning performant c'est le big
data
en effet quand on augmente la taille du
training day 7 le point de transition où
passent du régime dessous interprétation
à celui de sur interprétations se
déplace vers la droite ce qui correspond
à dire que l'apprentissage optimale est
alors celui de modèles plus sophistiqués
qui se généralise néanmoins bien en fait
de façon plus générale
unia a absolument besoin d'énormément de
données pour devenir une intelligence
artificielle intelligente
en conclusion albert je te conseille de
ne pas t'accrocher à des règles trop
compliqué et de garder à l'esprit que
peu importe les règles que tu choisiras
il y aura très probablement des
exceptions à la règle mais sans doute le
plus important à retenir c'est qu'un
échantillon d'une douzaine de pralines
ce n'est pas assez pour bien comparer la
belgique et la suisse surtout si ton
maître ne peut s'empêcher de manger une
partie de l'échantillon
un énorme merci à nathan laura et albert
de la chaîne la statistique a expliqué
mme rochât pour avoir participé à cette
vidéo et voir ce qu'ils font c'est
absolument génial je vous recommande
notamment vivement les vidéos sur la
moyenne versus médiane ou encore la
vidéo sur la paix valeurs qui avaient
que la régression linéaire et l'outil
statistique utilisée par la grande
majorité des scientifiques aujourd'hui
notamment pour tous ceux qui
s'intéressent à la philosophie des
sciences ce concept de paix valeur est
absolument fondamental il faut
absolument s'y intéresser l'anr fin on a
parlé de fat tonini dr turenne et cette
histoire de pièces qui tombent et eu le
choix de suivre surface et je m'excuse
parce que j'avais vraiment pas a pris le
temps de vraiment bien vous parlez de
pourquoi est ce que on peut penser que
la psp tombé plus tôt sur piles que
surface dans ce bar ya ce fameux
sophisme du parieur qui consiste à dire
que bombe à 8 face d'affilée ça fait
déjà beaucoup c'est un événement très
rare alors obtenir un neuvième face
d'affilée c'est vraiment très improbable
sauf que bien sûr à bien y réfléchir
la question que l'on se pose vraiment
c'est juste la probabilité d'un nouveau
face neuvième face et pas celui d'avoir
9 passes d'affilée
une hypothèse assez classique que l'on
fait souvent statistiques c'est le fait
que chaque lancer et indépendants en
particulier ce 9e lancée et indépendant
de tous les noms s'est passé et ça de
prime abord ça peut paraître assez
contradictoire avec la loi a été grand
nombre qui dit que si la pièce n'est pas
avisé qu'elle a une probabilité 1/2 de
tomber surface alors à l'infini la
fréquence des faces sera un demi donc
d'une certaine manière au bout d'un
moment et piles doivent réussir à
compenser les facettes d'une certaine
manière
en fait c'est pas vraiment ça qui se
passe et puis là les façons pas ce qu'on
pensait à l'infini en valeur absolue
c'est à dire que si je regarde le nombre
de piles - le nombre de faces ça ça va
pas tendre vers zéro ce qui va tendre
vers zéro c'est le nombre de piles - le
nombre de faces divisé par le nombre
total de lancers mais si je regarde
juste la différence pile - face en fait
cette quantité là va même avoir tendance
à grossir et alors le théorème centrale
imiteront la statistique a expliqué à
mon chat vous avez parlé montre même que
la différence donc deux faces - nombre
de pipe a tendance à être de l'ordre de
grandeur de racine carrée du nombre
total de lancers que l'on a considéré
bref tout ça pour dire que c'est assez
erronée c'est un biais cognitifs que de
penser que le nombre de piles mois le
nombre de phases devrait avoir tendance
à 31,0 annulé non pas du tout ceci étant
dit il y a quand même peut-être une
bonne raison de penser que le 9e lancé
sera plutôt pile que face en particulier
ce sera le cas si celui qui lance les
pièces est capable de déterminer en fait
l'issue du lancer de pièces et s'ils
pensent que l'on va prédire que la pièce
va tomber sur face à ce moment là si
c'est contre lui qu'on prend le pari
alors lui il a tout intérêt à dire
l'opposé de ce que l'on pense
et du coup si on pense que ça va tomber
surface il va avoir intérêt à faire
tomber ça sur piles du couple essaie
d'anticiper sa en donnant l'impression à
ce lanceur de pièces que on va parler
face au patois par les piles et ça se
rejoint un peu la remarque de france
avec pierre qui cède insisté sur le fait
que l'un des noeuds du problème ici
c'est de savoir si le lanceur de pièces
est capable de contrôler son lancer en
effet cette question elle est absolument
crucial si le pari est contre cette
personne mais si c'est juste un lanceur
de pierres s est amusé à lancer des
pièces et 6e 9e lens est pas différent
du 8e ans et en particulier si on
suppose qu'il n'y a pas de nouvelles
influences à ce nouveau lieu à me lancer
pour le lanceur de pièces je suis
neuvième ans et il aborde comme il a
abordé le huitième lancé et comme il va
aborder le dixième non c'est à ce
moment-là ça revient à supposer en fait
ce que notre part yves devait avoir
aucune influence sur ce 9e lancer du
lanceur de pièces et c'est un petit peu
le cadre dans lequel je sous-entendez
qu'on se plaçait la dernière fois bien
sûr en pratique tout est beaucoup plus
compliqué c'est intéressant de voir que
dans la vidéo précédente
rien que pour a réalisé le 10ème bio
variance n'était déjà d'une certaine
manière
dans un billet dessous d'interprétation
puisqu'on a cherché à simplifier au
maximum la situation qui se présentait
pour pouvoir la modéliser et pour
pouvoir introduire cette notion de 10 m
bia variance mais ça ça me permet de
revenir au débat est lancé alain fois
sur le fait qu'en cours de français on
apprend beaucoup à faire de la
surinterprétation et à peut-être
certains qui ont l'impression que
j'avais tendance à tabler sur la
littérature parce qu'ils ont fait que
j'aimais pas déroger dépanner dans fan
de littérature mais je pourrais très
bien tapé également sur un saignement
des mathématiques qui à mon sens on
encourage beaucoup trop las ou
d'interprétation si on a un dr john et
s'ils sont fichés du dr john c'est le
mec ultra rigide qui veut pas à
s'éloigner de ses modèles c'est aussi
parce que son nom de servane hier votre
formation souvent en mathématiques nous
pousse à la soude interprétation de
considérer que les mathématiques ça ne
s'applique qu'à des cas ultra restreint
et ça je pense que c'est très très
mauvais parce que sa conduite
typiquement considérer que ben les
mathématiques c'est un truc à part qui
s'applique pas au monde réel c'est la
tendance à faire tellement de la soupe
d'interprétation de des mathématiques
que on a tendance à complètement les
rejeter on attend ça pas vouloir les
modifier à l'est les interpréter un
petit peu pour coller un peu plus avec
les tenues et la fâcheuse conséquence de
tout ça c'est que dès qu'on aborde un
problème selon qu'ils soient posées de
façon mathématique ou somme qu'ils
soient posées de façon pas mathématique
de tendance à aborder de la question de
façon complètement différente dans les
deux cas et notamment je vous renvoie
vers l'épisode de 10 pour voir quel
point juste la manière de poser le
problème influence est ce qu'on voit le
sur interpréter où est ce qu'on va le
soudain terme était avec nous pendant
l'expérience de duncan en côte augustin
lazare et nitro font remarquer qu'il ya
moyen de faire en fait de la très bonne
interprétation de textes littéraires à
condition de bien connaître le contexte
dans lequel l'auteur a écrit ce texte
qu'elles seront assez d'influencé tout
ça est en effet il ya une superbe
analyse à faire autour de tout ça mais
ma critique de la vidéo précédente
s'adresse plutôt à l'enseignement pas
tant que la littérature elle-même sur
qui les chercheurs en littérature qui
font du
l'excès on travaille tout cas pas de
croiser énormément de données d'avoir du
modèle de compréhension qui ne sont pas
sur interprétations de l'équipe qui
prennent bien en compte suffisamment de
données pour éviter ce piège de la
surinterprétation ma critique de la
vidéo c'est le président s'adressait
plus à l'enseignement de la littérature
tout comme la critique des mathématiques
que je ne ferme et s'adresse à
l'enseignement des mathématiques
c'est ce qui m'intéresse en particulier
c'est qu'à ce que les élèves retiennent
j'ai bien peur que quand les élèves
suivent en cours de mathématiques et
lauriane cup
quand on a ce cette forme dénoncé
typique d'un exercice alors il faut
utiliser telles méthodes et que cette
méthode de résolution correspond
vraiment à ce qu'il faut faire
uniquement dans ce cadre très reste un
très mathématique et que dans ce cadre
mode m'appliquerai restanques a pas
trente six mille choses que l'on peut
faire n'est obligé d'utiliser cette
méthode uniquement et je pense qu'on a
en particulier en mathématiques
notamment modélisation mathématique le
peu de modélisation mathématique on fait
à l'école est vraiment largement de la
soude interprétations où on cherche à
enlever tout contexte dans
l'interprétation des mrc la team ico des
sujets mathématiques ça c'est très
pratique pour faire des corrections plus
tard alors que leur pratique quand on le
voudrait on faire de la mobilisation bat
s'est coupé compliqué puisqu'il faut
avoir un peu plus chercher à coller aux
données et bien al'inverse j'ai mes
repères que les élèves qui suivent des
cours de littérature notamment c'est mon
souvenir personnel je pourrais parler
longuement notamment d'un livre m'a
forcé à lire et donc je garde à ses
mauvais souvenirs qui le livre de
malebranche les terrains des livres que
je devais lire pendant mes classes
préparatoires ce qu'on me demandait de
faire davant pour préparer les examens
c'est un peu de cueillir certains
passages de malmanche et de les
réutiliser pour développer un argument
qui va un peu dans le sens de la
dissertation que j'étais en train
d'écrire
et ça c'est vraiment un cas typique de
rationalisation et de sur
interprétations des travaux de malmanche
voilà je pense que d'un point de vue
histoire de la pensée c'est intéressant
de se demander pourquoi est-ce que mal
broche à penser ce qui est proscrit son
genre mais d'un point de vue écriture
d'une dissertation pour avoir un maximum
de points au concours cette approche de
utiliser mal point un chat bon escient
en évitant absolument de critiquer en
disant que c'est un peu n'importe quoi
ce qu'il a dit sur les neurosciences
j'ai peur que ce qui en ressortent pas
c'est un peu une habitude à la
surinterprétation c'est quelque chose
que je trouve extrêmement problématique
est pas du tout souhaitable en temps
d'enseignement incroyables expériences
de faire remarquer que le problème
aurait été en fait
quelques est si au lieu de lui face on
avait huit piles et du coup au lieu
d'une chance aux 256 d'avoir un truc
surprenant en fait ça réduit à une
chance sur cent vingt-huit mois je vais
aller plus loin et veut dire qu'en fait
il ya beaucoup de lancers de suite
commencer qui donnerait l'impression que
l'on a compris quelque chose
par exemple si on avait obtenu pile face
pile face pile face pile face on a envie
de dire que le prochain ça va être un
pile la même façon si on avait face pile
face pile face face pile banon lui de
dire preuve que bouchehr sera face ou
encore à son avait pilpil fasse pas ce
pipe il fasse face on serait tenté de
dire pile ou en corse on avait face face
pile face face pil pil serait tenté de
dire face en fait si on regarde tous
épatants de la assez simple que l'on
peut voir surgir avec nous donne envie
de conclure qu'ils donneraient explique
mon avis un facteur de conclure que le
prochain ça va être sûr que ça met sa
main si on regarde en fait l'ensemble de
toutes ces hypothèses à considérer la
journaliste et du coup 8 et la
probabilité que l'un de ces arrive
lorsque la pièce n'est pas biaisé
elle n'est plus que d'une chance sur 3 2
c'est à dire que une fois sur 32 si la
pièce n'est pas biaisé fait toni va être
sûr de sa prédiction du prochain c'est
alors que la pièce n'est pas blessé bref
dans le dilemme gay variance en fait on
retrouve vraiment ce problème d'avoir
trop d'hypothèses à considérer enfin le
meilleur commentaire de la vidéo
présidente c'est une commentaires de
justin vaches qui nous dit que plutôt
que de considérer que la valeur de paix
est exactement égale à deux tiers ce qui
peut paraître assez arbitraire pourquoi
ne pas considérer toutes les valeurs
possibles de paix du coup essayer de
mesurer l'erreur de prédiction à l'aide
d'une intégrale tout leur possible de
paix avec peut-être même une intégrale
pondéré peut-être que
alors qu'une proche de 2/3 exemple sont
plus crédibles en instance que les
valeurs proches de 1 milliard
est ce que c'est vraiment le point de
base du bayer ni ses matisse est vrai
que les paramètres qu'on ne connaît pas
eh ben il connaît pas mais du coup on
peut peut-être décrire l'étendue de
notre ignorance par le fait qu'on me
connaît pas et qui jouit c'est un peu
partout et un terme à 0 et justement le
génie de la place c'est d'avoir fait
exactement cela et tout ça je finirai
pas vous en parler mais comme vous
commencez à le comprendre
elle espère que vous avez aimé cette
vidéo la pression on va parler du toit
fondamental de l'apprentissage
statistiques en particulier à essayer de
voir comment est-ce que d'un point de
vue purement théorique on peut essayer
de résoudre au moins en partie ce
problème du dilemme variance de savoir à
quel point ce qu'il faut coller aux
données du problème de fitting de van
persie sauveur pythie son interpellation
perçu ce surinterprétation bien j'espère
que vous avez fait sentir à quel point
c'était un problème extrêmement
importants difficiles que mal contre
encore aujourd'hui voici vous donne pas
de réponses toutes faites c'est parce
que je pense sincèrement qu'il n'existe
pas de réponse toute faite
et d'ailleurs même dans le cas du pays
ennemi qu'il s'agit d'une question qui
n'a pas du tout fait si vous avez aimez
cette vidéo pensez à la ligue et à la
commentaire partagé pensez à vous
abonner pour les épisodes merci au type
est un polar dont j'espère qu'il sera là
le théorème centrale limite mouche à
albert n'en a jamais entendu parler mais
les statisticiens eux lui vouent un
véritable culte sans le théorème
centrale limite la statistique ne serait
que l'ombre de ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui